ربما لاحظت ضجه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اليوم حول المشيحه في القدمين
كيف لا فهو اليوم العالمي للسير حافي
القدمين المعروف باسم جوبر فوتي
هو احتفال سنوي يقام في الاول من يوليو من
كل عام يتم تشجيع الناس على خلع احذيتهم
والسماح لاقدامهم بالتنفس واخذ الوقت
للمشي او الجري حافي القدمين قدر الامكان
تمت صياغه الفكره في اعقبك كارثه تسونامي
التي حدثت منذ اكثر من 15 عاما وادت الى
تضرر الكثير من الناس واغراقهم في الفقر
فتمت الدعوه لهذا اليوم لمساعده هؤلاء
الناس قدر الامكان والتبرع بالاحذيه التي
يمكن توزيعها على المحرومين المحتاجين الى
احذيه سواء كانت جديده او حتى مستعمله منذ
انشاء هذا اليوم تم التبرع بحوالي 19
مليون زوج من الاحذيه على مستوى العالم
ولا يزال يوم جوبر فودي يحتفل به في
العديد من البلدان حول العالم
والعديد من الدراسات اظهرت فوائد صحيه
ممتازه للقيام بذلك على كل حال سال الناس
في السعوديه وطلبنا من البعض الاشخاص
المشي حافيا في المكان المخصص لذلك
وسالناهم عن رايهم في التجربه نتابع
[موسيقى]
اسفه اشياء كثيره
تغير عندي شلون روتين اليوم بالبيت خلاص
صرت على طول يعني ابي امشي على طول يعني
لو اليوم لقيت فيما امشي احس بنقص
المتعارف عليها انه الافضل طريقه او افضل
وقت الواحد يمشي على الممشى الصحي طبعا
بعد اداء المجهود الرياضي
الممشى الصحي طبعا او المشي حافي القدمين
بيعمل على استشفاء العضله بقوي مفاصل
القدم امشي عشان القوي الدوره الدمويه
ودائما امشي هنا صرنا اذا ما طلعنا البر
ورحنا نمارس الرياضه هنا لها فوائد عظيمه
وانا انصح الجميع بالتعامل مع الممشاه من
ناحيه الرياضه النظافه لاهتمام شيء يعني
لا يوصف احنا علاج الطبيعي ننصح الاهالي
دائما يوجهون الاطفال بالمشي بالممشى
الصحي
ذلك مما يعزز قوه العضلات عند الاطفال
خصوصا في هيكله القدم يمنع كذلك القدم
المتسطحه
استقامه الساقين
[موسيقى]
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقاري
ر اللي ناتنه على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات